[Music]
[Applause]
licensed by my window is my chef dry in
the morning like a warning could affect
your foot day your heart because today's
gonna be a good day we're picking up
rode the airport and it's time for some
adventure
guys hello today we are right now we're
actually following some chickens I'm
here with a row
hello you believe this we happen is the
in Hawaii at the same time like crazy
we do not plan this isn't on it we did
it but we did plan this meeting yet it
but the fact that we're here at same
time did not plan yeah we were on
different island so I basically Island
hopped I'm like let's hang out with who
do something fun but I didn't know you
were gonna be in Hawaii this is so great
so right now texting right now so we're
going to do a canoe kayak well we're
going to be in the kayak and it takes a
little patient and then we hike in a
little waterfall and we did some of the
waterfalls and that's what we're doing
right now we're taking chickens yeah
this one is home to mom and little baby
they're everywhere
oh my gosh digging in the trash looking
for dinner they are breakfast lunch you
think you find any crab was that you the
baby one yeah that's what yeah little
one looks like we found a banana they
did they like fruit we used to give our
chickens watermelon and it be so cute
beginning like the watermelon like the
edges of it and they would just get it
and they love it I didn't know that they
eat fruit you know just being I'm
learning things yeah hanging out with
you because I thought they just ate the
grain but I guess if they're a wild
chicken
seeds and you can see whatever I mean
ate anything I saw some guy feeding were
cooking yesterday I was not happy about
that meeting cookies yeah I'm going to
be snapping our adventures I've also got
hat Co for you it's going to be sunny
but right now let's be a bit overcast so
Carson sounds
I follow you saw them foolish me and
you'll be entreated implied give me a
hard trip exclusively what I just saw if
you run away down thank you
I might have to go to the shore ah my
god the Hat Mike I have the true tourist
what's going on you do it looks good
right I have no shame and you know what
this matter over here we're going to a
good time and thankfully my phone is
water-resistant to be determined very
chilly glad what if I go in
we have anyone made it anywhere yet oh
yeah all right we're off are you
paddling already oh good it's going to
be so fun
as I try to get my go for the stick to
the canoe kayak but it didn't work so
maybe on the way back things will work
out a little better for now I'm in such
a great sound and we're going to Lake
I got into the I love you we look at
this great view okay hi guys hello
yay yeah how we going over there yeah
I'm taking a vlog break so how's it
going back there your hard drive within
this ball are my fingers hurt I'm
ripping it really tight I think our
handball skulls are in our favor unless
you like I usually keep to go like this
oh did it we made it I guess I could
take off my like mess now I made it to
our hiking destination it's one mile in
one mile back and I believe that we have
to cross the river yeah okay we'll see
what happens I got my drone in my
backpack so it might have to we're gonna
kick in their nesting well we see any
wild boar ah maybe I doubt it but just
my on Tuesday I've never seen one yet
and there's a group right in front of us
right Oh little a little guidance right
across we're about to cross this river
oh gee I look I just hurt so slippery
yeah oh my oh my little toe you got it
careful because the rocks are very hard
they're hard oh man probably got we may
have a cry like I hurt my little my my
big toe subd it but there's not much
protection on beaches at all
[Music]
how was it was again what I like is they
keep up to spell her husband even for me
it's a fright
pull up the whole the whole thing
[Music]
still alive what we're going through
another River this one is not a
difficult how dit lost my hat or my mind
everything goes well the water always
comes up so far on row we need to be
careful she's going to get swept away
[Music]
oh there I think it oh man
it's are we there we're pretty money
there yes all this is exciting
yeah so I mean might not drone see we
see what the shot looks like 125 feet
made a lot of all I was going to go in
but then it I got cold and I decided not
to so we're here
[Music]
[Applause]
since you're on a date I wasn't actually
able to get a GPS signal that would let
me take off any higher than what you
guys just saw view is so awesome and
they also immense ran out of battery so
you really think is it not we're not
working out for me today on the drone
front so beautiful and I got to say you
were pretty shocked you landed that
drone on a rock and a fat person to one
of these rocks she landed it over it was
rough I was afraid it was we get a leg
sometimes it doesn't feel like a feet of
surface to continue walking trees it's
making its way to sunlight but these
little waggy Wow there you go buddy this
one he is really indecisive hey where
are you going why is it awful my
guardian
making our way back to the kayak and so
basically everything we just did we're
doing it all over again but backwards
that's helping so something
I will create how it was like what a -
how can you hike in mile hike to the
fall mile hike back and I'm 2 mile can
you back here we are we're back and now
we're going to achieve ice dancing a
Claddagh Yelp Yelp oh my god I think I
make the love juice 9 waffle he's always
so good
which one is that oh wow it looks really
good my favorite tropical drink and now
it's a shave ice form it's incredible
I'm really excited look at mine and that
is just ridiculous massive oh here's our
coming up Wow thank you oh my goodness
can you believe it okay what did you get
a strawberry coconut strawberry focus
heavenly
you
[Music]
Oh